This transmission
is for future generations.
As it stands, a small sliver of humanity
is currently imposing their visions
on the rest of us.
They invest in space travel
and AI superintelligence
and underground bunkers,
while casting health care
and housing for all
as outlandish and unimaginable.
These futurists let
their own imaginations run wild
when it comes to bending
material and digital realities,
but their visions grow limp
when it comes to transforming
our social reality
so that everyone has the chance
to live a good and meaningful life.
We are in many ways trapped
inside the lopsided imagination
of those who monopolize
power and resources
to benefit the few
at the expense of the many.
And as I see it, there are two stories
these monopolists sell us
about what the future holds.
The first is the Silicon Valley version,
in which all our preferences
are tracked and desires catered to.
Chatbots, virtual assistants,
driverless cars at our beck and call.
All our wants and needs met in an instant.
This is their utopia,
where technology is our savior,
a future where our automated
offspring know us
better than we know ourselves.
Ease and convenience, just a click away.
And in their wildest dreams,
we merge with technology,
optimizing our potential
to be stronger, smarter, superhuman.
The other story, preferred by Hollywood,
is grittier, more chaotic.
Conflict and competition run rampant.
It's "Hunger Games" meets "Blade Runner"
meets "The Matrix."
People are ruthless and unpredictable.
Inequality and precarity
are permanent features in our lives.
In this dystopian vision,
technology is our slayer,
displacing and dominating humanity.
And while these sound
like opposing narratives,
they have different endings for sure,
one in which we're saved,
one in which we're slayed,
they actually share an underlying logic.
And in both, we give up power.
Both stories assume technology
is in the driver's seat,
propelled by a will of its own.
In the utopic and dystopic stories,
technology impacts us for better or worse.
But our impact on technology,
the human inputs, shall we say,
are missing.
The values, assumptions,
interests and needs
that shape our digital and physical worlds
are nowhere to be seen.
To move forward,
we have to pull back the screen.
Rather than agonizing
about a coming dystopia
or longing for a future utopia,
we have to reckon with ustopia.
Ustopia is a word I'm borrowing
from Margaret Atwood
to describe the fact
that the future is us.
However loathsome
or loving we are, so will we be.
Whereas utopias are the stuff of dreams,
dystopias, the stuff of nightmares,
ustopias are what we create together
when we're wide awake.
Ustopias invite us
into a collective imagination
in which we still have tensions,
but where everyone has
what they need to thrive.
When I was a grad student
at UC Berkeley in the early 2000s,
I witnessed firsthand how innovation
often deepens social inequity.
As the tech sector grew,
people who had lived
in the Bay area for generations
were displaced and discarded.
At the time, I was researching the social
dimensions of biotechnology.
As I observed scientists
growing heart cells
using pluripotent stem cells
beating in a petri dish,
I thought about how hard it is
to grow empathy for other human beings
in our everyday lives.
Here were billions of dollars being poured
into the future of medicine,
but health care for all
was somehow far-fetched.
This is what I mean
by a lopsided imagination,
where we can imagine
regenerating sick bodies
but not an ailing body politic.
Utopias require inequality and exclusion.
Ustopias center collective well-being
over gross concentrations of wealth.
They're built on an understanding
that all of our struggles,
from climate justice to racial justice,
are interconnected.
That we are interconnected.
Take what's happening in Barcelona, Spain,
where a large-scale participatory
experiment has been underway
for almost ten years now
using a digital platform called “Decidim,”
which means "we decide" in Catalan,
alongside in-person
neighborhood-level deliberations
to create policies that respond
to people's actual needs.
And the thing is, technology companies
are not driving what's happening.
The collective intelligence of people
from all walks of life are.
Proponents call it a “New Deal on Data”
that recognizes data sovereignty, privacy,
collective rights to data.
Decidim is open-source software,
so it's already been adapted
and used in over 80 other cities,
guaranteeing public transparency
in a way commercial platforms don't.
Once you install Decidim,
you can create, comment, consult on ideas
and track what happens in real time.
Over 40,000 residents
have submitted proposals
on everything from affordable
housing to air quality,
and about 70 percent
of the government's action plan
have been derived
directly from these proposals.
(Applause)
Take “Superblocks,”
an initiative to cut carbon emissions
and improve air quality,
where 12 city districts
have been closed to through traffic
so the interior blocks are more
hospitable to pedestrians,
cyclists, more green space.
On the Barcelona coastline,
another initiative is underway
in which residents are working
to make it more accessible to locals,
rather than simply a playground
for elites and cruise ships.
Notice how different this is
than the typical top-down,
"we know best" approach
to shaping the future.
Like what happened
with Sidewalk Labs in Toronto,
Google's urban development smart city play
that would have collected masses of data
data in order to create more efficient
and convenient city services.
But which in the end was tech-driven
rather than people-driven.
Sidewalk Labs staged public input sessions
in order to appear responsive
to residents' concerns
about the newfangled surveillance
that would have been embedded
into the Quayside neighborhood.
But people saw through the proposal
and put an end to the development.
In fact,
there are ustopias taking shape
right here in Atlanta.
Known by some as Silicon Peach
or Techlanta,
because it’s the fastest-growing
urban tech hub in the country,
it’s also the city with the highest
income inequality in the nation.
Which shouldn't surprise us
when we remember
that the fantasies of some
are so often the nightmares of others.
In many places, tech booms
actually exacerbate inequality,
increasing the cost of living,
displacing local residents
and creating high tech tools
for surveillance and social control.
But that's only half of the story.
Because here in Atlanta,
and in many other locales,
we're also witnessing
a historic mobilization of residents,
creating ustopias
that prioritize people over profit,
public goods over policing.
It started a few years ago,
when Atlanta officials announced
plans to build Cop City,
a massive 90-million-dollar facility
that would have trained police
from all over the country.
The development would include
cutting down Weelaunee Forest,
one of the four lungs of Atlanta
that protects against
heat waves and floods,
and which is located
next to a predominantly Black
working-class community.
But ATLiens were having none of it.
(Cheers and applause)
Utilizing direct action, digital tools,
a broad coalition has formed
to push back against the militarizing
imagination of the city.
Atlanta's forest defenders remind us
that true community safety
relies on connection,
not cops.
On public goods,
like housing and health care,
not punishment.
They understand that protecting
people and the planet
go hand in hand.
From college students to clergy,
environmental activists
to Indigenous elders,
they’re inviting us
into a collective imagination
in which our ecological
and our social well-being
go hand in hand.
An ustopia right in our own backyards.
And even children are pushing back
against the lopsided
imagination of city officials.
Like one who asked,
"What did cops do
to deserve a playground?"
As they sat in the kids zone
outside of the city council meeting
where hundreds of people
had showed up to speak out
against Cop City.
Together, they're reminding us
that deadly systems may seem durable,
but they're not inevitable.
And we don’t simply have to click: submit.
We can each work to strengthen
the social fabric in our own locale
and create a shared vision
in which no one is left behind.
We can follow the example
of data justice organizers in Barcelona,
forest defenders in Atlanta,
imagining and crafting the worlds
we cannot live without,
just as we dismantle the ones
we cannot live within.
The first step
is to stop policing the borders
of our own imagination.
A world without prisons?
Ridiculous.
Schools that foster
the genius of every child?
Naive.
Work that doesn't drive us into the grave?
Impossible.
A society where everyone has food,
shelter, love?
In your dreams.
Exactly.
(Applause)